こんにちははじめ社長ですここはスタジオなんだけども
ちょっとのターゲットを買い出すに生かされているんですけどももうすぐ玉帰ってくる
と思いますこれ使えるんじゃねみたいなものを見つけたのでちょっとそれを使って今回
ドッキリというか
ドキッとさせてみようと思いますジュンハ溢れたコーヒー
まあまあ右折気づいたでしょこれコーヒーが溢れたような偽物です
この部分ですねコーヒーが溢れてる感が出せるんですけど一回出してみましょうか
ネットで買ったんですけどすっごいであるだったんでそれが入ってどれくらいであるの
かっていうのはちょっと知りたいと思っております
おおあぁこれはがせる米うわっ8詰まっておかないとわかんねーよ
机の上におかあでもぽいなぁぽいぽいぽいこれでもコーヒーこうせたらあかんずに溢れ
てるはこれ前に溢れてますが横これは毛頭これ戻ってどう見ておこぼれてるよ
のがないと飲まナイトからにすることから始めネーター
プール人もこれで空になったからふーっ
コーヒー溢れている関数がなくないですかすごいやば5分待ってだいぶすごいよこれ
この版されちゃってはいはいというわけで早速この溢れたコーンを使ってアワーさとみ
て大事そうななんか何かあったらそこにちょっとコーヒー高生のふりをしておこうと
思います
[音楽]
バッハ
なくなるん
ん
me
いっ
持った
ん
両ざりお怖いです
a
あっはっは少ないと打球なんで year
ません
[音楽]
笑っん
ちょおいえっええっ
[音楽]
ん
ちょっている
あ
[音楽]
none
おおーー
[音楽]
me
teame
ああっああああ
me
re だった
いやーこれはヤバいでしょ完全にわかんないもんだな
こうやっててくれてちょっと入って寝込んで分けててこぼすたっぷりたいなぁおっけー
影響
[音楽]
分
ん
[音楽]
me
くん
んんん
ん
奪えずっっ
あっはぁああ設定は